[Music]
just started raining out of nowhere so
uh I don't know what condition these
roads are going to be in back here I was
here 3 months ago and there were a lot
of potholes which means there could be a
lot of
puddles which is not
good well we got our fingers crossed
we're going to see what we find so far
so
good God that beautiful holy cow you
guys see
[Music]
that
jeez I'm so
excited woo Mountain living
baby okay we made
it
yeah
woo home sweet
[Applause]
home
we last left off in Southern California
where we finished up the van build and
after that I headed north to Washington
[Music]
State
Washington is the last place I lived
before moving on to the
road and it's the place I technically
call home even though I don't have an
actual house or apartment or a place to
stay driving through the Cascades feels
like driving up my own driveway and I
can't help but gravitate toward familiar
trails and favorite
places but this time I felt strangely
[Music]
disconnected like I was wandering down a
hallway of old
memories rather than pushing myself to
grow and so 2 weeks later I found myself
on the road
again this time headed
[Music]
east
for
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a mount I've camped on many
times
before in fact it's one of the places I
camped in on my first extended trip in
my old
SUV before I moved on to the road and
was still living in montere
California I set out on a 5we road trip
through Utah Wyoming Montana and Canada
with nothing but the absolute Basics
every night I rearrange the back of my
extera into a sleeping Zone with a
blowup camping mattress wedged
diagonally up against the driver's seat
my sleeping bag and flannels and jackets
hung across my windows with the sleeves
tied together to form a kind of curtain
to block the Morning
[Music]
Light I remember thinking to myself so
many times during that trip this is
living like waking up every day
someplace new not knowing what to expect
not knowing who I'll meet or where the
day will lead something deep inside just
knew it was the life for
[Music]
me
being here reminded me of the days where
I felt uncomfortable unsure and yet so
excited like the time I jumped tandem
out of an airplane there was this moment
where I had already let go of the door
frame and hung helplessly from a chest
strap 10,000 ft above the ground just
waiting for my instructor to let
[Music]
go it was a moment of complete and total
surrender not yet falling but unable to
turn back
I felt at the very edge of life steeped
in fear but choosing to push
through I felt that here on this
mountain during that first road trip I
felt it when I left my hometown in the
midwest to live in Hawaii with almost
nothing to my name before I moved
overseas to Italy and again before I
moved on to the
road
[Music]
and I can feel it
now the seasons are
changing and so am
[Music]
I
all right this is the third campsite I
found up here on this
mountain it's the best one so far qu
save the
Spoto Yeehaw going to try to back in
over
here and wait for those people down
there to
leave
did you get me peeing over there
no probably a good
[Music]
call
wo woo
yeah that's such a good
jump oh wait this kind of counts as a
shower doesn't
it I got to take
advantage
[Music]
if I could tell 28-year-old me that one
day she'd be back in the same place but
with an entirely different life and so
many new and wild possibilities I wonder
if she would believe
me and if future me could tell current
me what life would be like 10 years from
now would I even want to know would you
want to
know honestly I don't think I would
living on the road and also just life in
general has taught me that there's so
much Beauty and simply not
[Music]
knowing
look at this meal Quinn just
made looks so good and this view woo
Teton
View
see this smell right now is making me
want to have an oven in my van you don't
have an
oven what do you do every night Cry 1
million yes what is the name of this
game monopo deal I like it because
you're
winning man look how much properties you
have yep prepare to lose
luck
last night a mouse got into the van at
3:00 in the
morning
and got it out but today I was working
at my computer and I looked over to my
right and there was another Mouse
sticking its head out from up here and
haven't gotten that one out
yet